DAVID KONERDING: Hello, and
welcome to Academics At Google
talks.
I'm really excited to
introduce Kai Kohlhoff today,
with whom I've worked for
the past four years at Google
on a project called Exacycle.
Today, he's going
to announce and show
some very exciting
results from using
Exacycle for
simulating proteins.
Now let me tell you a little
bit more about Exacycle
and why it's important.
Exacycle is a computing
platform at Google
that uses our massive
data centers to carry out
extraordinarily large
and complex simulations.
This has been a problem in
science for a very long time
where scientists were
not able to get access
to really large amounts
of computing power.
This has been changing
over the past few years,
especially with the cloud.
However, with the cloud,
there are a number
of things that you
have to do to optimize
your applications
to run very quickly.
So we built an application
called Exacycle
that enables
scientists to carry out
millions of core simulations
that run for months or years
at a time.
And then also,
because we're Google,
we need to be able to analyze
enormous amounts of data.
And so along with
Exacycle, we created
a technology called Flume, which
makes it really easy to process
large amounts of data.
So working with
Kai Kohlhoff, whom
I met four years
ago at Stanford,
we took the Exacycle
system and ran
some very complicated
calculations on it.
To give some background,
we do something
called molecular dynamic
simulations, which
are literally the application of
Newton's equations to proteins.
And if you run these
kinds of simulations,
you can often get insights
into how the systems work
and behave in the real world.
You can take those models
and that information
and use it to improve industrial
products and pharmaceutical
products like drugs.
And so Kai will give
a lot of details
about how the system works.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to give you a little bit
of an idea of how Exacycle
itself works and
why it's important.
So Google, in building
out its infrastructure
to serve search
results for people,
has to size its system
for peak capacity.
However, in the
middle of the night,
many of those systems when
people aren't searching
have idle cycles.
So we do is we
built a system that
uses our idle cycles
to do computing.
And we have a lot
of idle cycles,
because at peak, we have
to serve a lot of users.
So I took a system--
it was influenced
by SETI@home Folding@home.
We basically treat our
systems like massive farms
of desktop computers
available for computing.
This actually raises a number
of really challenging problems
such as dealing
with data at scale
and making sure that you
don't melt down data centers.
So after a number
of years of work,
Kai was able to run a
number of simulations.
And he's assembled
the results here,
and he's going to
be showing that
in advance of a
publication coming out
in "Nature Chemistry."
So without further ado,
let me introduce Kai.
I met Kai about
four years ago when
he wanted to be a
bioinformatics intern in Google.
However, he was a
post-doc, and post-docs
can't be interns at Google.
So instead, we hired him
as a visiting faculty
and gave him the
resources that he
needed to carry out his work.
Kai has now become a
full-time researcher at Google
and continues to work
on exciting problems.
Dr. Kohlhoff, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
KAI KOHLHOFF: Thank you,
Dave, for the introduction.
Yes, so that was actually
quite surprising.
I was hoping to spend three to
six months here-- just trying
to get some bioinformatics
algorithms working
with some of Google's
technologies.
And then after I actually went
through the whole application
process and was ready for host
matching, someone found out,
well, you got a PhD.
You're not going to be able
to come here or do anything
because we're not taking
PhDs for the intern program.
But luckily, they found a
different way of getting me in.
And part of that is actually
a pretty interesting part
of the story, which
really surprised me
as well at the time.
So just a little bit
further background--
I was working as
a bioinformatician
in the Bioengineering
department at Stanford.
I was mainly focusing on protein
simulations-- so basically,
physics-based simulations
of biological systems.
And with more and more of the
life sciences being treated
as information sciences,
there's this kind
of natural interest for
many people and Google,
for doing things at scale.
And also, just the
curiosity of it,
like how can things
work at this scale?
How do you efficiently work?
And it really came
as a surprise to me.
I had an idea that
some people at Google
might be interested
in biology or doing
bioinformatics applications, but
that there was actually someone
here working on
implementing a system that
was at least in part
inspired by the kind
of large-scale distributed
computing that we were doing
at Stanford and the kind
of science applications
we were working on.
That really surprised me, and
that was a very nice surprise--
being able to come here
and continue my work.
So I was working on
a class of proteins
called G-protein-coupled
receptors.
They sit in the cell
membrane and act a little bit
like a switch.
So you can imagine that
they sense molecules
from outside the cell, and
they switch on or off depending
on what kind of
molecules they are.
So for example, they
bind to epinephrine.
Or they bind to caffeine.
Or they bind to beta blockers.
So what makes them
interesting also
is that about half the
existing medication
interacts with
G-protein-coupled receptors.
So there's a big interest in
the pharmaceutical sciences
in this class of proteins.
So think about this.
Someone like me right now
standing here in front of you
and talking is probably
under a lot more stress
than the rest of
you in the room.
So you can imagine that I
have more epinephrine going
through my body.
And so you will actually
find a lot more active
G-protein-coupled receptors
telling my heart to beat faster
and telling my brain to
look out for predators.
So the thing is that because
all these processes are taking
place, you have to make sure
that any medication you send
into the body doesn't
interact with too
many of these receptors.
And that's actually
very difficult
because many of these receptors
are very similar in structure
and bind to similar molecules.
So for example, if you
take an Asthma medication,
it will bind to one receptor
and it will relax your muscles.
But at the same time, it will
bind to a very closely related
second receptor, and it will
make your heart beat faster.
So you have side-effects
that you want to avoid,
so that's why we have to study
G-protein-coupled receptors
in more detail and
understand how they work.
So let's take a look at one.
This is the system I've been
studying most of the time.
This is [INAUDIBLE] receptor.
And just for
comparison, you have
something like this,
which is actually
a relatively small protein.
It's three amino acids,
just put together.
Something like this has
about 340 amino acids.
So it's a very different scale.
But we can model
this on a computer.
To get a system this
from a database,
someone has taken the effort to
determine the structure using
x-ray crystallography,
so you know
pretty well where
all the atoms sit.
And then we just model that.
We take the 3D
coordinates, and then we
add a patch of cell membrane,
because this receptor
sits in the membrane.
So if you want to
simulate it, you
need to have the lipid
bilayer in there.
The next step-- you
have to put in solvent,
so it becomes closer and
closer to what you actually
see in the cell.
And then we add some
ions for good measure
to make sure that the
electrostatics work correctly.
And so now, you have
this protein in a box.
And this is your simulation
system, ready to work.
But to actually be able to
simulate this on the computer,
you need to apply
the physics of it.
So you need to describe
the system using
a set of equations.
And that's kind of what's
amazing about this system,
because people have been able to
create a set of equations that
describes all the
interactions between the atoms
and approximate the behavior.
And it fits on one
slide but still, it's
extremely computationally
expansive.
The one thing you see
here, the one equation,
is Newton's Second
Law of Motion,
and it's just saying if
you know the forces on all
of the particles in the system
and if you know their masses,
then we can calculate
the acceleration on them.
And that's what we're using
when we drive our simulations.
So here's an example--
an actual simulation one.
You will now recognize
the different parts.
You have the protein.
You have some ions here.
The solvent's not shown;
it would be too much.
And you have the
liquid membrane.
And so let's get this started.
Oh, that's pretty bad.
This is actually
what it would look
like if you had
very low sampling
and just save like
every couple of-- well,
not really nanoseconds,
but just, let's say,
every tenth frame.
So really on my screen,
it's very liquid.
It's very fluid.
And you can see how
the membrane moves
and how the protein moves.
But I think you get
the impression--
like how much it's
just moving there
and how much is just happening
in a very short time span.
Because, believe it or not,
this is three minute video
and it's only 5 nanoseconds
of actual chemical time.
So all of these
movements you see--
they happen on a
nanosecond scale.
And we have to simulate it
on the femtosecond scale
to capture all these
tiny movements that
are happening there.
So you have that.
You have to go from
the femtosecond scale
to the nanosecond
scale, by just running
the simulations for that long.
At the same time, you
have all of these atoms.
There's about 60,000
in this system.
They all interacts
with one another
through electrostatics
and van der Waals
forces and long-range
forces-- which basically, it
interferes with the
movement of all these atoms.
OK, so creating this movie took
about 10 days on a single CPU.
So there you have three
different time scales.
But basically what
it tells you is
that getting to the nanoseconds
takes days on a single CPU.
And it doesn't actually
show your that much.
In a nanosecond, what
you see is pretty much
only that one of these
little side-chains
here-- that may be in a flipped
position-- something like this.
So that's not really
telling you that
much about the activity of the
protein and what it can do.
So we have to run for
even longer time scales.
So what I want to
show this slide
is basically just the difference
between the different time
scales.
So again, for nanoseconds,
you might see a flip
in one of these
little side-chains.
And that might actually
be relevant already,
because it might mean
that some hydrogen
bond result which is formed.
And that might be the first
step of this protein doing
something.
So I told you it's
like a switch.
So basically, you want
to see does it switch on,
and how does it work.
But the switch would be the
whole protein doing something
not just one of the side-chains.
So we're definitely
looking for that.
We need to have that
kind of resolution.
We need to understand
how everything happens
step-by-step, but it's not
the most interesting part.
If you go to
microsecond simulations,
you're getting to
something where
you can see ligand
binding to it.
So it's a small molecule
coming from the outside, that
will be the top outside of the
cell binding to the protein
into the receptor,
and then it activates.
So that happens on the
microsecond time scale.
But microsecond's
already something
where you need a lot
of processing power.
You can do nanoseconds
on your own computer.
But for microseconds, you're
actually already pushing
the boundaries of what's
available to most people today.
But we want to go
further than that.
We want to really be there.
You want to be somewhere in
the milliseconds time scale
because that's when really
the bigger things happen.
That's when the whole receptor
has time to change shape
and activate.
Because all we
want to see is what
happens if something binds on
the extracellular side, what
happens on the
intercellular side.
Does it change shape as well?
And how does bind other proteins
and what happens exactly?
So to get there are,
basically, what's
you have available
in academia nowadays
is you have your
own workstation.
You can run these
short simulations.
You normally have
pooled resources,
like a group cluster which
has a number of 100 cores,
but it's shared.
You have to compete with
other group members.
And then you might have
departmental, university-wide,
or national computer
centers, which give you
maybe a few hundred
more CPU cores.
But all of these have in common
that you have to share them,
so it's pretty unlikely that
you get several thousand cores,
which you might need for running
long-time scale simulations.
So there needs to be
some other solution.
But the way it was done
so far is that basically,
you take this protein-in-a-box
and you subdivide it--
just split it up according
to all three dimensions.
And so if you have eight
cores, you just split it,
and you give each core one part
of the protein to simulate.
But then, you start
having problems
because you have to transfer the
forces across these boundaries.
So one of these
boxes has to know
what happens in the other
box, because otherwise
all your simulations
will go wrong.
But that's what
people have been doing
to speed up the processing.
And you can keep doing that--
adding more and more cores
and more and more subdivisions.
But since these
individual parts are
growing smaller and
smaller, you end up
having very little to simulate
on each individual core.
So you're spending more and more
time just transferring data.
And so like in many
supercomputing applications,
what you get is
imperfect scaling.
What you want to have
is this ideal scaling
where you double the
number of processors
and you double the output,
basically-- the efficiency.
But what you see here is--
what the reality of it is
is that you just add the number
of cores, but you lose a lot.
So after about 100 cores,
you're already down
to 50% of the total efficiency
that you could have.
And then it just
keeps flattening out.
So even if you had thousands
of cores available,
using this mechanism, it's
probably not very much
faster than having 200 cores
or something like this.
So this is not the way forward.
Eventually what we
have to do is run
several simulations in
parallel, and that way,
recover some of the
lost efficiency.
OK, so that's the other idea.
You just have a lot of copies.
And in the extreme case, you
just have one copy per core.
And now, you actually
have perfect scaling
because you just double
the number of cores,
and you get twice
the throughput.
It seems kind of silly to do
that because why would you
simulate the same
system over and again?
The difference is that you
introduce a random number,
and you change the
starting condition
so that each atom actually gets
a different velocity initially.
And so that drives
the system basically
into different directions
that evolve independently
for each of these simulations.
And so you spread it
out and use the sampling
over the available phase
space for your proteins.
And this is the idea
that has been followed
for more than 10 years by
Vijay Pande and his group
at Stanford.
So they have basically
had this system,
which is very similar
to SITI@home-- if you've
heard about that--
where basically,
people just download
a client program.
And while their system is idle,
they just run the screen-saver
and it computes work units
that it gets from Stanford.
And it does it for
a number of days
and then returns the result.
And then Standford goes about
and analyzes the results.
So there's something like
250,000 CPUs at any given time.
There's a problem
with this though,
because since these
are individuals,
these are people like you and me
just using their home computer,
they might decide to just
switch off their machine,
and maybe never switch
it on again or maybe
just not use the
screen-saver again anymore.
So you have sent out your work
unit, and it never comes back.
So you have to be aware of that.
So sometimes it takes
awhile until you
have sent out your work again
and have collected all of it.
It's also a shared
resource, but we
were able to actually
use this initially,
when I was still at Stanford.
And I did 10,000 simulations of
the protein that I showed you.
And so that was
a good start just
to show that the system was
actually stable and working.
But now when I heard from
Dave what he was doing
and what the scale
was, there was,
of course, a very
different beast.
Because Exacycle is
not just able to have
hundreds of thousands of cores,
but in excess of a million
cores working on your protein.
So now you can have your
parallel simulations,
and just have 10,000
jobs or 100,000 jobs
running at the same time.
It's a really good throughput.
So it's basically an enormous
batch processing system.
You just submit your work.
You eventually get it back.
Exacycle just goes out there
and finds the cycles for you.
You don't have to
take care of that.
And it was also part of
the grant program, which
gave away one billion CPU hours.
So that Google actually
showed that, you know,
just take all this compute
power that we have and just do
something good with it and
create some valuable science.
So we had a chance to work on
about 100,000 cores for about
half a year-- that's about the
years equivalent that we've
got.
So doing that, the
millions of CPU hours
obviously gave us a lot of data.
And that allowed us
to do something--
what you see on the
right-hand side.
So you start-- from the
starting confirmation.
Let's say that's A.
Let's say that it's
the off confirmation for
this switch that you have,
and then you just
start sampling.
You just spread out your work.
And then after a while, you
just collect all the data
and you look at it.
And you see like, OK, so which
of my trajectories, which
of my runs have actually
proceeded the furthest?
And where did I do
all the sampling?
The areas I've sampled
a lot-- I don't
have to sample any further.
So I'm just picking
some structures
for the next simulation run.
And I kind of keep
spreading out like this.
And so eventually, I would get
to state B using this process.
The other extreme is if we use
really specialized hardware
like on the left-hand side
where you have the Anton
supercomputer, which was
specifically built just
to run molecular
dynamics simulations.
But there you have
a number of cores
that work on the same protein.
And eventually, you have
a problem with scaling
where you can't have smaller
and smaller subdivisions.
But this is a way that you can
create a very long trajectory.
And the advantage is that
once you get from state A
to state B, you can go back and
replay this movie essentially
and just see what happens.
What are the dynamics
taking place?
What are the structural
changes taking place
to get the protein
from one to the other?
OK, so that makes it easier.
We have a lot of data now.
And actually coming
to Google, suddenly I
had like two orders of magnitude
more data to work with.
So that's a bit of a challenge.
So what you do with that?
The answer is, of course,
go back to the cloud
and do the analysis there.
So we used something called
Markov state models that
was also developed
at Standford mainly.
And it basically takes all
these individual trajectories
and it clusters
them together so you
have a number of
different states.
But because these small
trajectories actually
sometimes migrate from
one state to another one,
you have these
transitions as well.
You get a probability
of how likely
it is that a protein that starts
here goes to this other state,
and then in comparison
to whatever other paths
it can take.
So like this example shows there
might be several different ways
that you go from A to
B. And actually, you
might go back sometimes as well.
So actually, these arrows
should go both ways.
But that tells us something
about what's happening.
And in our case, analyzing
all the data that we had
showed us that you have
a number of pathways
that go from the inactive
state of the receptor
to the active state.
And that's actually something
that we didn't anticipate
and something we weren't
sure we could actually see.
So we basically just
let the simulations run,
and we were just
letting ourselves
be surprised by the outcome.
There wasn't really
a clear plan how far
we might be able
to get with this.
But it was amazing
to see how far this
lead us using all the
compute power that we had.
OK, so now when you
have the pathways,
here's one thing you
can do with that.
So you know the protein
goes in different ways.
Now you can see like, OK, what
happens with these molecules--
the beta blockers
and things like that
that bind to your receptor
that inactivate it.
And so you have two
different examples here
where basically you just do some
talking between the molecules
shown here and the
big protein and just
see along this pathway going
from the inactive state
on the left to the active
state on the right--
so basically the percentage of
progress along that trajectory.
Where does this bind?
And the interesting result
is that, for example,
the one on the top, which
activates the protein,
it doesn't bind
in the beginning.
It doesn't bind in
the inactive state.
You actually have to process
along the activation pathway
for awhile before it
actually starts binding.
So that's interesting
because if all you
have is the inactive
state and you
think you want to develop
a dark molecule for it,
maybe the most efficient
dark molecule doesn't bind.
Maybe because the protein
in it is fluctuating
between inactive and
active to some degree,
you need to have something that
just goes to the active state
and then stabilizes it.
And the other extreme
is the second example,
which is actually
inactivating the receptor.
And similarly, it mainly
binds to the inactive state
and it's not really
on the protein
the whole duration of a change
from active to inactive.
So you can take
this into account
when you start developing
dark molecules.
And there's a lot more
information in there.
We've actually
written this up, and I
think there's more than 40 pages
in supplemental information
in the paper that's
coming out, just
doing this kind of analysis.
OK, and just to summarize
the results-- so
what we've shown really is that
you can use cloud computing
to do these kind of simulations.
And it's kind of the way
that you think about it.
Basically, what people start
out with is they just learn,
OK, we just throw more
and more CPUs at it
and we just
subdivide it further.
But people are not really
aware that some applications,
if you find the right algorithms
and the right approach,
you can actually go to the cloud
and be at least as efficient.
And in our case, we actually
have created the largest data
set for G-protein-coupled
receptors.
And that was only possible
because of the last scale
that Exacycle enabled us to use.
This shows that
the cloud is there.
The cloud is
something we can use
as a useful tool that
allows us to scale.
It allows us to have
capacity when we need it,
and not have to wait for
the couple of hundred cores
that I want to run for
the next three weeks just
to see whether or not
my experiment works.
The other advantage
is that I was actually
given a lot of time at
Stanford to start researching
G-protein-coupled
receptors, and that's
something you might not
necessarily have at a company.
So in this way, by just
working with scientists
from university, you get kind
of the best of both worlds
where you can do the fundamental
research at the university,
but then take it to
scale and basically
throw all this
compute power at it
and get somewhere
very, very quickly.
The third thing is that
hopefully, in the future,
scientists don't really
have to bother so much
with setting up their
own servers anymore
and the technical aspects of it,
but just basically send it off
to the cloud, someone
else takes care of it,
and you just focus
on your science.
It's surprising
that a lot of people
don't really know that Google
is doing research in any field.
I keep getting that feedback.
But that Google is doing
something in biology
is what really surprises
a lot of people.
And I think this way, we can
also create the awareness
that not only is Google
doing some research,
you can also go as a
scientist and use Google
for doing your research.
And then hopefully, as a
big vision in the future,
you have everything
in the cloud.
You have the data in the cloud.
You have the analysis
in the cloud.
So you start having this
kind of continuous progress
where people can go and
continue working their data
and reproduce the results.
And then they just do their
own analysis on top of it.
And so basically, you
have shared resources.
You don't have to have this
silo building that everyone
does their own things
and doesn't share.
But you can really
collaboratively go about it
and have continuous
conversations
about this research.
And this is probably
the slide that
makes me personally the proudest
because after almost five years
of research, we have been able
to now get a paper accepted
in "Nature Chemistry"
summarizing all the results,
working on Exacycle
and the hard work done
at Stanford with our
collaborators here.
And so I'm actually showing
the different people
involved at Google
and at Stanford.
And the cover page
here that will
be the cover page of the "Nature
Chemistry" issue in January
coming out next week
and it was created
by one of our colleagues in the
[INAUDIBLE] group, [INAUDIBLE].
And so he helped us to
actually get us on the cover
and be featured there as well.
And so, yeah.
So that actually
answered and just shows
that we've had impact
with this program.
OK, thanks a lot.
Actually, I think David
wants to say something
before we have questions.
DAVID KONERDING: Thank
you very much, Kai.
That was very exciting.
It's really thrilling to
see after a number of years
of hard work that the
science has paid off
and that our ideas
are making it out
into the academic community,
and we hope we have an impact.
And further, what
I'd like to say
is that Google has,
over the past few years,
started to enter
the cloud business.
And my feeling is, after seeing
this project work successfully,
that I think our cloud
is ready for science.
And I think as a
scientist, it's really
in your interest to understand
how to use our systems
and take advantage of them.
Because in the future,
access to enormous amounts
of computing power
are going to make
the difference between
successful scientists
and unsuccessful ones.
So if you start looking at what
we're doing and read our papers
and figure out the
techniques that we're using
and look at open source
projects like Hadoop,
you should start adopting
the idea that were promoting
and that the Hadoop
people are promoting.
There's a lot of
really great ideas
there that help
scientists focus more
on the interesting
questions they have.
And that's really what
science is about--
is attempting to answer
questions, less so
the actual engineering
of how bytes move around
between computers.
[APPLAUSE]